[موسيقى]
وصلت إلى هنا في عام 89 وأنا الآن
أصبحت حيث أنا في الجزيرة التي لا أفعلها
كنت أرغب في رؤية أي شخص ولكن لسنوات عديدة
كان خياري أن أعيش فيه
الاتصال المباشر بالطبيعة ه
ابدأ من جديد بطريقة مختلفة
أعتقد أنك يجب أن تكون الحياة
في الواقع لم يتخيل مارلين ذلك
وصل هنا عرضًا بدون حتى
لتعلم أن الحارس موجود
أنه كان من قبل
بعد يومين من رحيله كان أ
القليل من الحظ أنني أخذت مكان
الحارس السابق
انظروا لا يوجد شيء
الجمال هو المكان الذي لا يوجد فيه الإنسان
مرحبا بكم في مسكني هنا لا
يصل خط الكهرباء لذلك س س
مزروعة بألواح كهروضوئية
كل ما عندي من التيار للمياه
مياه الأمطار لأنه لا يوجد أي منها
يتم إعطاء الدورات أنا أقدر لا شيء السومو
هذه شجرة عيد الميلاد الخاصة بي و
هذه كلها أشياء ذلك الرجل
يعطي البحر لأنه كريم جدا
الرجل
من يوم مختلف سواء في الصيف أو
في الشتاء والشتاء عندما لا يأتي أحد
العام إلى حد كبير بمتوسط ​​30 40
كتب كل شتاء
لقد قلت دائمًا أن لدي الكثير
أصدقاء كما أكرر هؤلاء كثيرا ه
أشهر هي الكتب التي
إنهم لا يخونونك أبدًا
في الواقع يجعلونك تصدق أنني أعرفها أ
ذاكرة
أعرف الذاكرة التي تعرفها الذاكرة
من الواضح أنني أصبحت قليلاً من
عالم النبات
هنا هذا هو الشاطئ المتآكل
تبدو قليلا كم هو رائع
لم يمسها شيء والآن لم يعد كذلك
الكثير من اللون الوردي 94 جاء ثلاثة آلاف
الناس كل يوم بوعي
لا شعوريا كانوا يرتدون لنا يرتاح
البيض طوعا في واحد
زجاجة داخل أكياس النظارات
البلاستيك استغرق 70 20 عاما
تدمير ما تمتلكه الطبيعة
صنع في عشرة ميلان
وأنا لم أعد تلك المجاديف لأنني
في السنوات الأولى
لقد وضعت بالفعل بوابتين في الطريق
بحيث لا يستطيع أحد الدخول
كنت أرغب في التواصل مع أي شخص ثم أنا
أدركت أنني أردت فقط
هذا الجمال وشعرت به
شعرت بأنانية جدا لا أنا عادة
سأضعهم هنا
[موسيقى]
لقد عاملني جيدًا كما تعلم منذ 29 عامًا
لم امرض ابدا ، ولا حتى اصيب
البرد
الشتاء أبدا
أعتقد أنني سأبقى هناك حتى
الاحتمال المادي ولكن لا يسمح به
الدورية تناسبني لأنها كذلك
مقتنع بعد ما يعمل
في ذهني لا يزال كثيرًا
سلمية وهادئة وأعيش بشكل جيد
حتى لوحده
أحب الشجاعة وبودا تقريبًا يقول ذلك
آرامين بوه لكني أعتقد ذلك